being 27 years old making 12 dollars an
hour and being happy is a gift being 27
years old and having your parents pay
for your life is a huge vulnerability
I've been having a lot of Doubt lately
my 21 year old who's graduating
everything that you've just said
when I tell you parenting is just like
politics right now we've gone way too
extreme and everybody has to get to the
middle as fast as humanly possible if
you want to work at Walmart good if you
want to be an entrepreneur fine but
you're gonna have to do that here's
where parents get caught they talk big
game but then they pay for the kids Uber
they talk big game but one of the
parents undermines the whole by
slipping them 100 bucks you can't do
that if that kid's such a big boy he
needs to stand on his own two feet I
feel so much better and so much more
proud of him and myself because you have
reinstilled what I've always tried to
teach him so thank you for that thank
you very much so happy for you and by
the way you live with four friends right
and do the bare minimum for him to go
go the way the way you'll do that is by
not giving him a dollar